I'm CR Capri and I play monster Finny
hey i'm jessica marie garcia and i play
jasmine Flores
hey I'm Diego Tinoco and I play Cesar
Diaz I'm Jason Jenelle and I play Ruby
Martinez I'm Bret gray and I play Cham
all Turner okay catch a bag oh and we're
gonna take a quiz from BuzzFeed to
figure out which character fruit on my
block we are all right what's your role
in your squad we have the leaders of
rebel the muscle we get our squad or
like us as you would you're right in my
locker
I'm gonna pick the mother head because
I'm always trying to take care of her
I'm gonna pick the individual no the
cautious one I think the individual just
because it depends whether or not that
one the rebel likewise I picked um the
individual as well okay if you work on
the run where would you go first okay
your best friend's house your parents
house the police station not the police
the bank your secret hideout you
wouldn't want to involve others I picked
my best friends I'm gonna pick my
parents either my mom is gonna hold me
down right okay she's gonna give me out
I want to know who picks the bank right
well you ever know look you know I think
you can't go to the bank get the money
and then go see your family down in
Mexico you know hang out you're pretty
more say no that's well you know it's
not my first week on the run from the
police
am I on the run from my friend and my on
the run from my parents who's not gonna
cheat on you no matter what about run
from I'm not going to police station
either way then I'm gonna cut you
wouldn't want to involve others because
I'm so selfless who's another iconic
squad to be a part of so the options are
the squad from the Chilean adventures of
Savannah and fire from a cheer squad
from elite the squad from stranger
things the squad from sex education and
the squad from big mouth I'm sure our
beautiful colors here you know I'm gonna
say big mouth because I was thinking
that sorry okay I think I'm gonna do
chilling adventures of Sabrina because
like the whole like witchcraft stuff is
he vomited each year
no Mindy really do it again black boys
i'ma do easily was fired but I'm scared
what's a must-have item in your go-bag
hair gel iPhone charger a good book
first aid kit hand sanitizer in the
clubs well it depends what I'm doing
handsome what's the Go Bag for right
like we need all of these things I'm
gonna go an iPhone charger because the
uber will be going back home after
likewise iPhone charger for sure I saw
you big hand sanitizer what you we
should go back I just don't like I
always thinking to take me shopping
I might have to pick first aid kit
because I am such a mess I run into
things that aren't even near but if you
have a class on you can go I break my
leg playing mini golf
so you can be like help me yeah she died
but she was ring if you happen to dig up
a large sum of cash what would you spend
it on a sweet ride home for your parents
a designer handbag save it for a rainy
day
blend it among your friends though a
state-of-the-art bunker my friends would
not split money that they dug up with me
I think that's like I'm gonna do it
cause any tell these people get out
bunker because we are in a climate
crisis it's not a joke
we're all gonna burn under the Sun your
kids are not the trees are man
extinction is gonna be among us and
running rampant if we don't get it
together that was such a Jamal fees oh
wow I'm be in my bunker cute with Wi-Fi
and she could live in the bunker I
picked a home for your parents because I
was raised with some sense yeah likewise
I would definitely give my mom and my
dad
how good are you at keeping secrets yeah
whatever you tell me goes into the vault
I'm gonna tell my close friends but
that's it
I'll keep your secret as long as you're
safe or not in trouble if it's juicy
I'll probably tell everyone I'm
basically a sieve a sieve I knew that
isn't that on Star Wars every everything
goes through me yeah and then a lot I
don't be telling nobody secret what
secret I don't know no secret I'm gonna
say whatever yeah whatever you tell me
goes into the ball all right oh my hi no
I was gonna say as long as you're safe
yeah I'm gonna tell clothes but this is
I might have to I picked
I'll keep your secret as long as you're
safe not in trouble oh that's actually a
much better answer when I feel like yes
finally for fun
pick a no me no me no me hanging by the
pool help me with sunglasses no me with
food on his face but I survived that
might be me I'm no me chilling with his
noemi's and funny oh no me he looks
black I think I'm gonna do the one
chillin by the pool I pick no me hanging
by the pool that's my favorite line ever
when he is like oh we haven't even
reached max oh yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna
do I know me with sunglasses actually
yeah I got Ruby I got jasmine oh I
wasn't expecting to say I got spooky I
got Caesar
oh I got Jamal why did that bad it was
the bunker question buzzfeed you are
incredibly accurate yes thank you have
so much fun stream on my blog yes
[Music]